I've always considered myself to be an
accidental architect when I first went
to college I went with the intention of
being a musician but one year in I hurt
my right hand and at that point I
realized I could draw a little bit and I
started taking architecture classes
drawing classes and eventually graduated
from college in both a major in
architecture music I must say that to
this day music continues to inspire me
and I'm also very inspired by the way it
can communicate and it has got to do
with architecture in in many ways and
constant little reminders from
daughter she reminds me that the beauty
of architecture is not just about the
looks but about the inner character and
the soul of our architecture I think an
important project would be the house in
three movements that we did and one of
the challenges was to create a viable
domestic environment for our family of
four
the myths are very difficult and narrow
sight and the idea came from music I
thought of creating a house in three
movements literally three parts and it
was important because apart from
organizing spaces it was an opportunity
for us to think about how to create a
range of spaces that can evolve as the
family progressed and developed on a
different scale altogether we were
invited to do a series of residential
towers that we had actually not done
before the important part was that we
had to translate what we were used to
doing at a domestic level to a much
larger urban scale and I think good
design is something that must concur and
resonate I think it's important because
this keeps the design process
interactive between designer and the end
users
[Music]
you